Fontanella north of bucharest
Roma have been living in the village for
generations there are hundreds of
families no one knows exactly how many
but for some time now people have been
leaving Fontanella more and more of them
are leaving their homes and moving to
Germany
preaching about the journey to the
promised land is pastor do me through
God alia paradise for the Roma is one of
the toughest parts of Berlin the NOI
cone district we are praying for Angela
Merkel and the mayor of Berlin dear lord
please protect these people
pastor goda Leah says he'll stay until
the last person has left he lives from
donations and what he can raise in his
garden like nearly everyone else here he
doesn't have a job they keep shutting
off the water we only have water for two
hours a day that doesn't happen in
Germany if I were rich I'd pay for my
entire parish to travel to Germany
Alexandra Mariota doesn't have anything
nice to say about the government either
earlier he earned more money playing his
accordion at weddings and parties and
was able to feed his family of 11 but
during the economic crisis no one has
money to pay musicians anymore
so he's trying to earn money selling
used cars but he says exorbitant taxes
on cars are going to put him out of
business they want 2000 euros to
register a car that's not worth 1000
euros people moving to Germany meet in
front of his house every day they want
to go where the government supports
people and pays welfare and child
support that's 20 times higher than it
is in Romania
just you can say hakuna mrs. kasuba
German economy is strong money legit and
the Germans are good with their money
God has blessed them he loves them so
much that they share their money with
the poor and they can take in others who
come in from abroad castor pot is a tree
especially Nevada Colo it seems an
education and good knowledge of German
are often secondary considerations on
zwei drei poops
6c bit of noisy
Berlin no cone is located 1,300
kilometers to the northwest
thousands of Roma have already moved
here this building in the hot Sun ASSA
is where they're headed more than 500
people live here and more keep coming
a Catholic resettlement organization
bought the houses and furnished them now
the Roma feel at home here but most of
them keep their distance from the locals
this is a and there are very tightly in
that community connected and they're
finding each other here again they know
they're in a strange land so they've
become even closer
annamaria burger and Torsten Schnee have
been administering the place since 2011
Baga is a psychologist of romanian
descent she's one of the first people
the newcomers go to even when it comes
to getting work she employs Roma with
trade licenses to renovate the buildings
nearly all of them are licensed mine
given hot Mary Jean I have a few
businesses in caretaking cleaning
drywall and tiling avoided anything
wrong talking about freezing and if that
doesn't bring in enough there's always
welfare schemes Dinah give you there are
a few here who have received rent
subsidies in the Job Center because they
don't earn enough in total because I'm
gonna be living yet socially integrating
the Roma in Berlin will be much more
expensive
kevin conroy they can barely speak
german and don't know the laws at all I
know that will cost money more money and
that's why it's a tough in Berlin Berlin
Davidge tava Dhaka has made it unlike
many others here he's learned a trade
and he can just about live from what he
earns his children attend German schools
the nine-member family is proud of their
small flat with its living room set and
flowered wallpaper in D felony winter
it's unbelievably difficult for a long
time we lived from hand to mouth but it
doesn't matter we're trying to build
something for our children's future this
is much much better than in Romania
Yoshi family in general
back in Fontanella Samina Mariota also
wants to take her children to Noi cone
she says passports and the bus ride will
cost 3,000 euros but she doesn't have
the money she says that this is where
she'll have to bathe until then
what I'd love to go to Germany I can
already imagine what it's like to live
there but I don't think my dreams ever
come true before the beanie in the
evenings pasture to me through again
causes congregation to prayer
God should touch the German people with
his hand God should bless the German
people it looks like the Roma exodus
from Fontanella will continue